[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys and today we have
zukio
zuckerberg
fabulous filipino bro hey
mr
zuko slash rufio that's you see what i
did one of the original careful boys all
right one of the original careful uh
lost boys
what other intros i got [ __ ] i'll
take any of that [ __ ] uh michael
jackson backup dancer as a kid dangerous
but he was all right what else we got
[ __ ] faking the funk take the lead
keep it coming baby the day
but i but i'm a cheerleader but i'm a
cheerleader
i'm good last time we talked about that
one gay scene where somebody threw you
up on the [ __ ] wall ahead of me yeah
i
the other day we had a guest and he was
like oh so who else is coming and i was
like oh um dante bosco he goes wait and
i was like he was like rufio what how's
that possible and i was like that's true
man every time i think about it like
we're so
like friends now that like i forget
i forget like
and also it's how we met because we
didn't mean like so officially remember
at morongo mad at playing poker yeah i
had a casino dude that's right yeah with
uh
the manager of no you got who is he
managing poreotic
oh that dude yes yeah i know ooh right
which which manager that's three oh
that one the shady shady we're just
throwing money around
oh yeah you guys were throwing this
money around
but you were in line
you were lying i was and i was at the
table
who was up who was down that's what
that's why you look so this is money
money joe was with
fraternizing with the periodic manager
can we found your money i was just
[ __ ] at the table chopping it up you
know
but you're getting like subway or
something and you're in line and i was
like oh [ __ ] that's that's [ __ ] dante
pasco
and then he was like you want to go say
what's up to him
and then and then we just said hi and we
went up at the same table and then we
wound up on the same table yeah it was
one of those like um cool what's up nice
to meet you and then we're playing poker
in the same tape do you remember that
grandma that night she she was she was
chill until she loses every time she
loses she was mean as i don't remember
her and i love taking money from that
old [ __ ]
yeah this thing is i'm usually pretty
chill at the plug table joe don't give a
[ __ ] old people nothing
like you try to be nice to me i like i
won't you know i won't let them go i
won't push them all in i won't like lean
on them
joe's like [ __ ] it i'm gonna [ __ ]
take this little [ __ ] for everything
she got
my wife she might be on social security
joe
the last money she'll ever have at least
she'll have social security right yeah i
just like it because i feel like on a
poker table
that's that there's no like there's no
humanity there that's just there's no
humanity no you go you're you [ __ ]
came to play that's the battlegrounds
bro there's no times out like i don't
care if you're a grandma i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah and she tried to play that [ __ ] she
tried to play that nice [ __ ] like
that's we're having a great time and
every time she loses she's mean bro so
that's why i was just like all right was
she like fine though
she's a grandma dude that doesn't negate
for me
she could be a guilt find grandma in
your life you know guilt not my style
although stevie weeby says that he
really likes older ladies because he
knows he could bust inside and not get
him pregnant
[Music]
whoa
wow that's true there's something
with our bodies that you know you know
time has changed they're getting older
and they stand you know it fit longer as
you get older do you feel you find
yourself attracted to older ladies
well if he gets older they get older too
yeah they're all saying maybe we all get
home as you get older do you find
yourself still thinking like 18 year
olds are hot as [ __ ]
look at this trap he said he got just
it's a question i don't know
he's not gonna relate to you on that man
beauty is beauty see this is why he's
[ __ ] in zuko dude i got a question
for you guys okay so if you miss your
ex-girlfriend and you fantasize about
her you're not a pedophile don't why are
you doing that
don't do that don't do that if you miss
her
from time to time just for moments right
yeah
and it was that time in your memory when
you were 16. when you're 16 14 whatever
junior high i got my 16 year old hat on
does that mean you're not a pedophile
because you went back in time or are you
a pedophile because
she's underage now and you're
fantasizing about it you're not going
back in time it's a memory
it might just flash through your head at
that time
you're not like like okay in order to
access my memory i have to become a pet
so you're young in your head too i think
i think either way you just keep that to
yourself uh i'll tell you
how to remedy that how you remedy that
is you just go on facebook and look for
her right now
and then and then you go all the way
back to when she was yeah and then
you'll see the modern [ __ ] you're like
oh [ __ ] it'll snap you right back
[ __ ] just that [ __ ] she's got three
kids and it's successful [ __ ] like all
the time that i reminisce about sucking
on my mama's titties
i don't go like oh yeah she was amazing
when i was 38 mm sucking on my mama's
titties i think the baby bar
oh that was so nurturing why do i feel
like the baby bar's still there you
understood the nourishment
breast milk as a baby i don't know i
mean this is too much stress for me man
my girl is like 13 years younger than me
right which is still in her mid-30s but
still like
it's just we have some friends that you
know
the dating [ __ ] goes all over the place
when you start thinking my friend that
girlfriend's like 20 years younger than
her but he's like 50 and she's like 30
something she's still old as hell but
but still like think about that is he
you know back in the day be a pedophile
in his mind yeah true well yeah i mean
that means it's like when you were
[ __ ] 14 she was like right crazy but
like we're not going to do that math no
don't do that math
not 14 13 i said god oh you said you're
right yeah
are you trying to say that they should
just make pedophile illegal no
is that what you're trying to i thought
you were just couldn't find the right
words or something no no no no no no
i remember
to find the right words i remember one
time
i was like passionately like making out
with this girl just i said i said some
super corny [ __ ] i was like oh my god
where the [ __ ] you been all my life and
she's like underage
damn she has good crowd work yeah yeah
yeah good crowd she's a comedian stop so
fast and we started laughing so hard and
i started tearing up [ __ ] dying dude
because it's hilarious imagine the other
one damn where you've been all my life
over age
didn't now as a person underage did you
ever hook up with someone overrated oh
we
talk about that we tried let's hear your
version we already talked about it now
now that you're obviously there because
you've got superstars dude his is
different because he was famous yeah i
would like to win a writer
no i was 16 i was dating this 26 year
old which is
weird was my dream whoa i wanted to all
but i lied about my age
i was saying i was 18 nights i mean that
tiffany amphitheater of course when i
was 16 i look like i'm probably 12. but
who was it who's it nobody nobody nobody
you know you're younger in hollywood you
you're around adults all the time so
you're like around older yeah so it's a
so so so you me you're you're dating a
[ __ ] grip
but you're the wardrobe you can get a
wardrobe or hair makeup look look we
know why you're here we know why you're
here dante everybody wants the hollywood
secrets i know it's secret like everyone
wants
we know you got secret studios
y'all gonna get me in trouble because i
got cons and [ __ ] and people be saying i
saw you on jack kenny's oh no that's
what jk news is about we couldn't
uncover the news i literally at every
con now a few people come up to me and
be like i [ __ ] with you because i see
you on jk see they [ __ ] with you and i'm
like looking at this person like
these [ __ ] are trying to get me
in trouble on that show will you tell us
more about this 26 year old no she was
just cool yeah the key grip how'd you
beat her now that guy's been at a party
i don't know if she's a fan or not but
you know i was just i was lying about my
age the whole time you know she was a
fan were they from the lighting
department you said you were 16 at a
time i was 16. you're you're looking at
you're like i'm 12 [ __ ] no i was like
i'll send them 19 20 or something i'm
like you know you're like i'm 20 then
now i'm 19 like i'm 18 and they're like
was this after hook that's after hook
she's like calling me oh my well i had a
pager back then right she's like paging
me and i'm like she's giving you boobs
i'm calling her from high school like
well i'm at school right now she's like
what call i mean at college i'm like uh
yeah yeah i'm at long beach city college
i'm a grad student what if she was lying
about her age and she was also underage
that would be hilarious dude you can't
win with that's too big of a lie
i'm 26.
there's no nothing you just you just
take people out their word and i
remember abg's back then always lied
about being part filipino when they were
just chinese or something what advantage
is that because it's hot like all the
girls on import tuner were some filipino
girl i never knew that
maybe it's uh hold on we got roofio fans
here
oh yeah yeah oh where did it go
somewhere it was under the car
under that mercedes oh you took it in to
protect it
i mean i told you yeah
the world's a good place no no there's
an evil ass [ __ ] who finally had
guilt right up his spine and it was like
i better give this [ __ ] back because
these thin ass walls got holes in them
yeah no way yeah was here now
i choose to believe in the world as
being hopeful
i hope they hope they can keep their
stolen possessions that's what they hope
there's good people when's the last time
you stole some [ __ ] that was a long time
after we already got back come on baby
you know what are you doing yeah i got
the dog in here too hey
remember look at you
so somebody pick up the dog and show the
world oh the dog's here we gave him a
lot of chicken remember when we were
joking i don't want to scare him he
looks scared is this is he is he is he
is he a random dog no he lives he does
he came here before let's bring it back
to
dante because everybody everybody's been
asked in the comments everybody wants to
know how many fans you [ __ ]
damn everybody else each one of my
fingers is going to represent the
denomination of 10.
it's ted each yeah what's that this is
40. and i think you guys all got me
that's all artists there's a dog here
there's a dog here somebody brought a
dog in here
oh my god is this a dog dante was about
to give us how many girls did you
[ __ ] die
[Laughter]
no fans
out dude it's not good to [ __ ] fans i
think i think the [ __ ] paradigm
dude go away
no i think so i mean look you guys are
you guys all have fans everyone has fans
here don't worry about us you have the
most though but everyone has fans this
is the deal i think that i really
honestly think there is a relationship
that we have with the fan base
and you shouldn't violate that
relationship by well what the [ __ ] has
joe been doing his whole life
it's not a violation
it's extra access
it's a it's the highest year of patreon
the highest patreon
you were but you were in a relationship
for so much of that i know but the other
thing is because there's too much
expectation
you know what it is too much you can
never live up to that we can never live
up to that i like so the difference is i
don't like die hards and mega fans i
like someone who's like
oh oh you know i think i saw a video yes
i think i yeah that's not really a fan
that's just someone who you don't think
people want to [ __ ] have sex with
this guy and be like hey when you bust
can you please crow
has that ever happened that has never
happened that's never happened you
[ __ ] cool you didn't find me bro did
tell me she was in love with me since
she was 15 like in the middle of the
situation damn
oh wow i didn't really you know you
didn't know what's going on and you're
like oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
damn and then you crazy maybe we should
be doing that oh we crawled all right
that's when you stick your thumb in her
butt
oh
i get in my head too much you know i
have a simple guy
ah let's focus on more wholesome things
yeah you were recently in hawaii being a
pastor
complete 180 dude i was not a pastor and
an
how did that happen that's crazy i
thought you had to be a priest to do
that well
aj raphael and his wife alyssa now
rafael they asked me to officiate their
wedding in hawaii of course you know
like he's like my little brothers i'm
like 100 let's do it but then i'm not
obviously i'm not a priest or anything
or a minister so we have to go find a
way to get that done a few clicks of the
internet
and i'm
ordained i'm ordained i can do this now
you could do it over and over again now
i'm minister for hire y'all just hit me
what do you got what do you got to click
just the traffic lights
no no yeah yeah new traffic lights for
sure which one's a boat i don't know
it's really easy i'm gonna call the
crosswalk i did like some
non-denomination i mean when you think
about it's all just like i don't it's
weird
the whole wait so even though they're
filipino they didn't do like a a
catholic type of serious traditional a
few different weddings
why do filipinos have 10 weddings i
think they have a church this is just
like gosh so they already did like the
veil and the bees that represent the
whatever the [ __ ] and you came in you're
like this is the homie wedding i did a
couple crosswalk clicks and [ __ ] like
that
identified the bicycles you're right and
then your man it was really very simple
it was surprisingly simple to become
i mean what is it anyway what kind of
power is do i you know i said the power
invested in me what power is that that's
like cameo now right yeah i don't even
know
you said that whole speech too with the
power of this i i didn't say i didn't
just i did something that claimed them
man in white and i signed the marriage
certificate i also signed the marriage
so there's some powers wow
so i was like you gave him an autograph
too yeah
that's a two-for-one you could sell that
i'm surprised he didn't do a lost boys
themed wedding you know it's like such a
waste you have dante he could have been
rufio and then you could have done a lot
we were in hawaii we we were in the
jungle we were in the jungle like you
come in jurassic park you come out butt
naked right and then there's just like a
little bamboo armor and it's just all
hanging there and you walk through it's
like
oh
so invested in me when i be sick as [ __ ]
and you get to save money on the banquet
invisible food dude it's make believe
this is true
so there was a lot of musical stuff
going on yeah yeah and like singers all
everyone i feel like everyone in the
damn movie i mean everyone in the damn
movie and then the wedding could sing
seem like i'm sure like yeah
that's so cool man the tupac of uh
hawaii the good morning hawaii guy yeah
yeah the good morning
is that him chloe kai yeah i see the
tupac
because he's the most like played artist
there i guess is he no because tupac's
the most played artist is he dead
no
he's like
he's like rv
he's more like yeah nsync of hawaii or
some [ __ ] i don't know
right next to each other
he's like classic r b his voice is crazy
he was starting soon i didn't realize
how old he was i listened to all his
music and it sounds like a like a young
guy's voice yeah and you see him and
you're like dude this guy's like a news
anchor
i mean
dallas reigns
that's a funny comparison that's an
adult of our news anchor he got a news
anchor look but he got the voice of like
a like a young kid
so is that this yeah yeah are you
planning are you planning on being an
officiant for more weddings was that
something like you enjoyed or is that
something that you're like i'm gonna do
this for my boy i'm careful i do it for
aj that's it before the power runs out
that's it i mean i have to renew the
power i think yearly
oh that's how they get you it's like a
licensing fee it's like crossfit it's
like exactly i got to do that for hawk's
wedding coming up next month you're
officiating cool you have power i got to
do the same thing you did
not yet no are you guys best friends
getting married that's awesome yeah you
going to do it like an sda church
no it's yeah he's happy he's having a
crazy ass destination wedding like where
morocco
morocco
is artsy [ __ ] man that's very
hot you know that's very muhammad it's
very hot yeah how come no one asked me
to officiate it
i'll do a good job i think you guys who
officiate
david you got david you gave david power
to officiating yo he was just he was
actually gonna be a pastor that's why he
already had the david was gonna be a
pastor isn't that crazy to flock
he was gonna have morals isn't that he
has morals though that's so cute of you
no he's not he's not like a [ __ ]
degenerate like me and joe he has
morales yeah
he just talks big and goes crazy but
he's not he's never like [ __ ] i don't
know he's a he's a son he was gonna be
he was gonna be a pastor yeah yeah
but he did stand-up comedy instead yeah
he's a church youth leader he got good
morals yeah i know a lot of koreans that
are hella good christians they're like
hella good christian koreans hmm there's
a lot of koreans that are hella good
christians yeah that's what
david saw though koreans love church
and golf it is fascinating church and
goals yeah you see like the korean
sounds the same jesus being korean like
in korean like how the [ __ ] did jesus
get to korea
there was like literally i'm in new york
and like this is also sitting next i was
like walking down street and i was like
a korean lady i was by koreatown she was
like disseminated in the streets for
like jesus like middle-aged cream and i
was like looking at her like i heard
they did how the hell
i'm like that's like the crusaders on
hollywood boulevard they're all korean
the ones that shouted you would have the
signs there are westboro baptists dude
faith is cool whatever i'm just like
damn so that's taking it to another
level you guys ever seen that movie
silent or silence what andrew garfield
or some [ __ ] um
you want to talk about that
i know andrew garfield thank you he was
fine man yeah i know he's like he's like
this uh christian priest goes on a
mission to this land right trying to
spread the early gospel at this time
where it's like uh they [ __ ]
you know if they don't accept you then
they're gonna [ __ ] put you down
yeah so then they like i think it's in
asia too it might have been crazy i
don't know but they [ __ ]
um said he's got to denounce his
religion of christianity and stuff like
that so then they put him in like
torture sequences they like put him in
prison and stuff and the entire time he
has to like silently continue his faith
and stuff and i watched his like a
three-hour movie this drama i watched
that airplane jesus christ produce i
watch it
and then you just it just ends and he
like dies spoiler alert
and he dies
hopefully holding on to his faith
and there's nothing that makes you feel
good about it or inspires you in any way
is that the point really thought that i
wasted like three hours of my life but
did you cry is that the point of the
movie though isn't that isn't that the
message maybe
maybe but i think that's how you're
going to feel at the end of your life
right
i'll throw my faith away for anything
yeah you literally scared me right now
ryan is wild no i'm just kidding we're
all going to heaven
we're filipino we grew up having fake
catholic faith which is also very
questionable
i already did the full lap man i'll
abandon my faith for a good deal man
like what what's the minimum buddhism at
50 off yeah like give me two give me
like ten percent off msrp i'll abandon
my faith i'll be whatever which faith
are we talking about anything what do
you think i am i don't know i don't know
which faith you are i found out i was
buddhist without being buddhist
the way i think oh you did a survey
yeah what i thought i was i found out i
was buddhist without being like harry
potter
i'm probably closer to buddhism too yeah
after i studied buddhism i was like oh
[ __ ] this is kind of like naturally what
about atheists
i guess so
that's agnostic
i guess so
i was always like before you really want
me to be in this bible situation i need
you to point out where
it says filipino
[Laughter]
our korean
like i need you to like say
where they [ __ ] with any asians and
said this also pertains to the asians
it's two and then it is zero
like you need to before i'm following
you to the [ __ ] gates of hell i need
you to say follow me show me
where the [ __ ] city is
you need some brother yeah this is a
representation i there's not no
representation it's just jewish and
romans there's all these people roaming
but also we're going to meet some asian
people later on when we get there y'all
are [ __ ] with me too we're going to
cross that street nope not even i'm not
following we need yeah they had giants
in the bible they had giants were they
chinese the filipinos then yeah exactly
but wouldn't it be crazy because i get
it i do get to buy one people like oh
the romans is like you know that's where
i'm from i'm like romans and jewish it
seems like the jews like oh that's part
of our [ __ ] yes your promised word yeah
[Laughter]
right and then he was trying to like
preach to me and then he said like
um
you know have you like gotten a
christian and i was like no i had this
one question that couldn't be answered
he goes what is it and i said so
if like christianity happened and then
jesus came what about all the people
before that like all the mayans in south
america all the asians everybody else uh
they never heard the word of god so do
they go to heaven he goes no you have to
accept jesus christ in your heart and
i'm like that's a mean god because
there's a lot of people that never had a
chance to know him and they just died so
they're just going to hell by default
because they never had the chance and
i'm like i can't believe that religion
yeah that's something hey look it's
paper thin that's why praise to be allah
so how many fans you [ __ ] though
the dog was asking not us
[Music]
you